how did you get started in the business
okay so I study film and college at NYU
I always wanted to be a filmmaker movies
that kind of stuff and I learned how to
work the camera and at NYU film and made
some student films stuff like that and
then I switch paths at college and went
to study something else and gave up film
regrettably and after college I went to
Wall Street and I was therefore if i was
i was working on wall street from about
95 till 2000 and I was miserable I just
hated it I really hate it I wanted to
make movies or right or do something
creative and I spoke to a good friend of
mine named Michael judge wonderful guy
really interesting guy Michael with a
why worth looking into and I said
Michael I'm miserable I hate what I'm
doing I'm making money and so forth but
I really want to do something creative
I'm scared though you know I it's I
don't know what it is exactly I want to
do but I'm afraid to let go of what I'm
doing because I'm making money and so
forth and it's just clear path but I'm
really miserable in fact I had a
girlfriend at the time and I said I just
want to quit my job and just right maybe
make a movie and she laughed at me she
actually left him is she was like you
just can sit around all day and write
and and I spoke to Michael and I said
this is what I want to do I want to just
quit and he said you have to do that he
said think about what the world would be
like if people did what they were afraid
to do I was like okay thanks and I
didn't do it for another couple years so
but several years two thousand five ish
I spoke to a good friend of mine named
Gary Winnick who was a filmmaker and I
said the same thing basically I'm
miserable I really want to make a movie
at that point I had written one script
it wasn't very good but I had completed
it started and finished it and it was a
good feeling
and ice again I said I'm miserable I
hate what I'm doing and he said the the
technology right now is incredible
there's a new camera that just came out
called the dvx 100 which is a very sort
of cinematic look to it when I had been
at NYU film school video was sneered at
it was you know it was garbage there was
actually a coffin at leaning against the
wall of the film department at NYU and
spray painted on it was death to video
because video was was very um it just
looked shitty it just looked very
one-dimensional and cheap and it was
clearly video and this new technology in
about two thousand four or five there
was texture to it and it was it was cool
it really looked cool so he said just
get the camera and just it just
make it so that's basically what I did I
quit my job I wrote this script I was
interested in this topic monogamy and I
knew i was gonna direct it and write it
myself and I was just like yeah it
so I made that movie and that was sex
and sushi and that's sort of the short
version that sort of led to my somebody
saw at New York and wrapped it and it
played some festivals and then I moved
out to Los Angeles and somebody else saw
it and asked me to write something else
that got produced and yeah that was it
though
you